first up we're kicking it off with pete
davidson because why not everybody loves
talking about him
so much so
that it's just like everyone's like
there's something about pete you know
it's pete
fever and
buzzfeed collected a sample of reasons
from the internet and here's one okay
here's a quote he seems like the kind of
guy who isn't afraid to hold a woman's
purse yes okay
interesting interesting i know that's
important for some women for some women
yeah i think it's sweet in my case it'd
be like do you want to sport my
transport backpack
um another one he has a good
relationship with his mom i do like this
one majorly important to love your mom
it really is coats i know it does you
don't have to have had a great
relationship with your mom to be someone
great in the future that doesn't have to
be your journey but we love that he
loves his mom i think they live together
in staten island isn't that the truth
okay that might be going farther
but they did at one point you know what
it's working for him that's all we need
to know he's basically the golden
retriever of men oh
yeah
um i guess that means loyal lovable yeah
trainable
[Laughter]
and uh finally someone said he's like a
dirty string meme with the mouth of a
trucker
i didn't realize that that was an
exciting requirement in the dating world
there there is something about him right
and it's so funny how much debate he
just causes in general the fact that he
dates the most beautiful famous women in
the world but can you imagine every
you're pete davidson and every tv show
you turn on every magazine is like
debating whether or not you're
attractive or like what it's like like i
kind of get it though like
do you people have pete fever
do you think you have pete fever i just
love men who are funny and i do know a
bunch of people who know him and work
with him
and everyone
i'm very kind of reputation oriented as
far as behavior at work so i am always
curious about how people conduct
themselves and every report about him is
just what a lovely person he is funny
thoughtful
thorough kind
just
exemplary behavior you know what pete
david said you got to come here and hang
out with us we want to get to know you a
little bit
please
[Applause]
right love you we do love you i'll get a
neck tattoo
just for i am in oh that would be a
delight like no other well that's an
invite pete see you soon all right next
up we all love a good puffer a puffer
jacket you know to get us through the
cold months you guys cold out there but
is a puffer appropriate in every
scenario well it's the great debate well
it can feel like a very casual coat
vogue reports that celebs are insisting
that a puffer is perfect for any
occasion take a look here's rihanna and
kim k and puffer okay new york they look
chic really eyelash here she is working
the red carpet and a bagel puffer one i
love and i think it's because it gives
me color
color changes everything a little
structure too what about little nausea
uh he's very right
that's what i wear friend yes
oh i just love him me too no you you
strike me as someone who would wear a
puffer do you know what i am not a
puffer fan really i feel like it it
thickens me up you know it's like
strapping a bunch of like steaks and not
in that good lady gaga way like it just
makes me feel like and this is how i
feel in a puffer yeah okay i'm walking
around i'm in a jacket i'm walking i'm
walking i'm walking i'm walking here's
me in a puffer
yeah completely
[Applause]
i don't
i think you have got to really have a
certain body type you've got to have
certain accessories when you're looking
at rihanna and kim k
they are they've got leather going on
with that puffer they've got headdresses
and adornments and um but what you need
to do when it comes to a puffer is don't
get that box shape that's not flattering
on anyone no find one that has a looser
more flowy uh fabric to it
um or has a cinched in waist otherwise
you're gonna look like the michelin man
totally how many people get that
reference totally hello clap if you know
the michelin man yes
[Music]